les chaînes humaines à l'encontre
d'alexandre loukachenko se multiplient
cela fait maintenant près de deux
semaines que les manifestants protestent
contre la réélection de leur président
qu'ils estiment illégitime
s'en est suivie une répression violente
qui ne semble pas arrêter les
contestataires biélorusse habité par la
colère l'opposante de loukachenko
svetlana tirano sky à qui s'est replié
en lituanie il ya plus de dix jours
continue elle de combattre son
adversaire depuis le pays voisin le
peuple bélarusse n'acceptera jamais le
leadership actuel le peuple n'acceptera
et ne pardonnera jamais cette violence
que nos citoyens ont subi lors de
manifestations pacifiques
j'espère vivement et je crois que les
autorités entendront leurs peuples le
président répète qu'il aime son pays et
son peuple et ce qu'ils voient
maintenant lui envoie un message clair
que les gens veulent des changes en
parallèle les soutiens de l'homme
pouvoir depuis 26 ans se mobilise
également comme ici à brest dans le sud
ouest du pays ce jeudi emmanuel macron a
proposé une médiation de l'union
européenne une suggestion loin
d'emballer l'actuel président biélorusse
marc cluzel est 11e tournoi chuck bass
ed a déclaré qu'il souhaitait assurer
une médiation dans les négociations en
biélorussie laissez-moi y aller en
premier je ferais l'intermédiaire entre
les gilet jaune et makro il faut voir la
situation de saison joue de nous en
garde
la terreur les gilet jaune il ne voit
rien non ils sont obsédés par la
biélorussie qu'ils s'occupent d'abord de
leurs propres problèmes
les allemands ne parviennent pas à
résoudre le court aux navires us il y à
des manifestations
pourquoi sont-ils obsédé par la
biélorussie c'est une bonne occasion de
détourner l'attention de ses propres
problèmes pour l'orienter vers un autre
pays
ghoul une situation politique tendue
dont l'issue reste très incertaine
selon le président français et la
chancelière allemande angela merkel
alexandre loukachenko reste pour le
moment fermé au dialogue avec l'europe